my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner hey everybody it's
Charlie this is gonna be my ready player
one Easter Egg video obviously
everything in the movie was an easter
egg or it was covered in Easter Egg
graffiti like if you look at the walls
there's a graffiti on everything because
of the post-apocalyptic environment
everything is covered in like Pixar
Disney pretty much anything from the
history of video games in the world like
it gets pretty crazy so technically
there's hundreds and hundreds of Easter
eggs i limited this list because I
didn't want to make a video that was
gonna be an hour long so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
movie yet but in no particular order and
sort of combining a couple of different
video game Easter eggs and things just
to keep the list down the Star Trek
funeral probably one of the funniest
jokes of the film he just gets right up
out of the coffin
Batman helping people climb Mount
Everest all the other DC Comics Easter
eggs the Adam West Batmobile during the
race you have Deathstroke Harley Quinn
The Joker Artemis is a Kyra motorcycle
the Speed Racer Mach 5 the van from the
a-team the Bigfoot monster truck
the DeLorean that he drives that's been
modified with the lights from KITT on
Knight Rider there are a bunch of Star
Wars references when he completes the
first challenge anorak says nice job
Padawan they also have an r2d2 replica
sitting in their apartment at the end of
the film Sorrento tried to tempt him
with the Millennium Falcon you have the
Millennium Falcon in here oh yeah I can
get that for you the whole end game raid
environment is set on Planet doom from
Voltron there was even a lion from
Voltron during the big final battle and
we'll talk about that in a second that's
also on my list but there was so many
Easter eggs during that I tried to
condense that one down this is a mecha
Rubik's Cube that turns back time Robert
Zemeckis directed the Back to the Future
movies one of the funnier ones was I
Rock name-dropping the classic Tootsie
Pop commercial how many licks does it
take to get to the center of the Tootsie
Pop get to the center of a Tootsie Pop a
good question there were a couple
Jurassic Park references I know that's
been in the news lately because they
just announced Jurassic
three they added the t-rex obviously the
most famous character from that
franchise you probably also heard about
the Arnold Schwarzenegger Last Action
Hero Easter egg because people were
talking about that last week that was
playing in one of the theaters along the
race circuit in that first big sequence
the Robocop Easter Egg the people were
talking about was featured on a
billboard it was Delta city that was
mentioned that's the city from Robocop
because Iraq also quoted Hamlet a lot of
people were taking the skull that formed
his body to be a hamlet Easter Egg too
when he said the Steampunk Pirate King I
knew him well Sorento and also when he
pulled out the special shield that they
activated later in the film it was in
the box from gremlins that gizmo came in
they even gave Gary Gygax from Dungeons
& Dragons famous shout out by saying the
gold mines of Gygax there was the Clark
Kent Christopher Reeve Superman disguise
you could tell it's his version of the
character because of the way the glasses
are shaped the Iron Giant probably the
literal biggest Easter egg next to
Mechagodzilla but also probably the
biggest laugh in my theater was the
Terminator 2 Easter Egg when it went
down below the lava and did the big
thumbs up that Arnold gives at the end
of that movie sort of getting into that
big final battle scene so obviously it
gets insane here you'd have to pause the
movie and go frame by frame at least 30
or 40 different times to catch all the
easter eggs because literally every
character or every couple of groups of
characters is from different IP from
video games from movies there's the
secret weapon Chucky that he whips out
oh my god it's Chucky there's the group
of halo Spartans there's chun-li Ryu
from Street Fighter also appears earlier
during the race there's the overwatch
characters Duke Nukem Freddy Krueger
Jason Voorhees the battle toes and the
Ninja Turtles both in this big fight
which is funny because the battle toads
are kind of like the knockoff Ninja
Turtles Batgirl even shows up I even
thought I briefly spotted obi-wan Kenobi
but it was kind of out of frame and it
moved by a little too quickly so I can't
confirm that one of the biggest classic
Easter eggs is one of the challenges
from the books the original Easter egg
from adventure on the Atari they wound
up switching the order of some of the
challenges in the books but I can
understand why they saved this for last
there's parseval's hadouken from Street
Fighter when he's defeating Sorrento
Sorrento zav ATAR himself kind of looked
like an evil Superman
version of his own face but it's made to
look like Sorrento's face if he were an
evil version of Superman creepiest
Easter egg winner goes to that whole
sequence from The Shining in the second
key creepy naked old lady in the bathtub
is probably one of the most haunting
moments in all of cinema I dare you to
go watch the real version of that at
some point and I love the way that they
referenced Stephen King when they were
talking about the Creator hates his own
creation because Stephen King absolutely
hated Stanley Kubrick's treatment of The
Shining movie completely different from
the book especially with the big hedge
maze ending to that but I love the way
that the movie used that for comedy
there's all the outfits that he cycles
through when he's trying to figure out
what to wear when he's gonna meet
Artemis at the club the Michael Jackson
Thriller outfit Prince's Purple Rain
costume probably got the biggest laugh
out of me buckaroo banzai obviously a
deep cut the joke about holidays
favorite first-person shooter being
Goldeneye on the n64 I wasted so much
time playing that game slappers only
mode she gets pissed off at him I know
what slappers only means they even
turned the logo of the movie into an
Easter Egg like you traveled through a
maze here and you get to the center of
the oh and it's an actual egg meant to
represent the egg that they're trying to
find at the end of this movie overall
I'll say you know without doing a
full-blown review of the movie because I
don't think that's totally necessary it
worked it was fun I know a lot of people
are back and forth on how it treats pop
culture but if you understand the book a
little bit even if you haven't read it
you understand that that's like the
whole point of this is that it swims in
nostalgia for pop culture I feel like
nobody but Steven Spielberg could have
brought this movie together you'd have
to be a really powerful person in
Hollywood
to get everybody that owns all these
different IP to agree to let them be
used in the film I'm sure they had to
pay a lot of money for some of it but
because Warner Brothers released it I
think that's why you're not seeing any
Marvel characters in here that was a big
question people like why are there so
many DC characters and so many from
other different companies but there's no
Marvel stuff in here since I'm right the
film itself is really like the Roger
Rabbit of present day if you haven't
seen that movie
it's amazing go back and watch it Robert
Zemeckis also directed that like you
know there's so much back to the future
during ready player one Robert Zemeckis
is
so responsible for Who Framed Roger
Rabbit which involves a lot of Disney
sharing IP with Warner Brothers which is
just a crazy scenario that you never
think would work out I'm sorry I yank
Charisse and if you look at the laundry
list of requirements that they had for
each of the characters you can see why
some of them are featured very briefly
and why some of them get really long
continuous shots like The Iron Giant is
featured very prominently several
different times but some characters only
show up in like the corner of the frame
or in the background I think that was
part of the bargaining arrangement like
we'll let you use our characters Warner
Brothers but they're only allowed to be
used in specific scene
you can't show them certain ways but if
you spotted any really cool Easter eggs
that you loved that I didn't mention
during the video just write them below
in the comments like I said there are
hundreds of them so you could watch the
movie five or six times and still find
new stuff but that's kind of the point
I feel like regardless of how much money
it makes in the theaters it'll do well
on home video and streaming just because
people want to spot all those Easter
eggs there'll be a whole bunch of
trailers dropping in the next couple of
days between Marvel's Star Wars and
everything else that's coming up so be
sure to subscribe to get everything if
you're just finding me for the first
time leave all your requests for bonus
videos in the comments below to Monday
is the national championship so I'm
expecting a couple trailers to drop
during that but while you wait for
everything click here for my brand-new
infinity war video and click here for my
last big Easter Egg video for Thor
Ragnarok thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight